it's a deal that comes after more than
two years of doing business together in
2011 Nokia hitched its fate to
Microsoft's Windows Phone software the
decision to sell its main handset
business has been likened by one analyst
to Nokia collapsing into the arms of
Microsoft but the American software
giant isn't spinning it that way for
Microsoft it's also a signature event a
signature event in our transformation we
think this is win-win for employees
win-win for shareholders and win-win for
customers of both companies samsung has
unseated Nokia as the biggest player in
mobile phones Nokia now has just a 14%
share of the market it once dominated
Apple is number three crucially Nokia
isn't even in the top five in the
lucrative smartphone market as its
fortunes have dwindled the company has
laid off thousands of workers there are
fears more could follow for all of us at
Nokia today there is ambiguity and
concern because it is so hard to know
what the future holds for each of us but
elopes own future is clear the former
Microsoft executive will return to the
company and is even being tipped as a
successor to retiring CEO Steve Ballmer